- So I'm going to start from my childhood.
My mother created the perfect big
because at the age of
five years old
my stepfather started
priming me to be molested.
He started, I don't
remember really this time
but my mother said when, when
she would come home from work
because she worked 11 to
7 and he would babysit us.
But she said she came home sometime.
And I would be in the bed
with him at the foot of her
bed with no underwear on.
And she's like, what are
you doing and asking me?
And she said, and you will
look like so shocked that like
I don't, I don't know why I'm in your bed.
And he would explain to her
that I got scared and I had
a bad dream or whatever.
And I'm with the VA got to be about him.
Now, mind you I'm five years old.
I never get scared.
My brother was playing with the dog.
He would be in my bed.
He was the one who'd pee in the bed.
I would change his sheets
and hide them underneath all
the clothing in the closet.
So he wouldn't get a whooping.
These are the things I would do
for him at five and six years old.
So I was the responsible one I never,
so it just didn't click
to me that why wouldn't you
think something was wrong
with your father, with him,
with your five-year-old child?
And, and I don't get it.
I don't get it.
So when he,
when he had sex with me
I think I was like 9 or 9 or 10.
I don't remember.
For some reason I can
remember almost everything
but that specific actual event.
And my clinician told me that
my brain was so traumatic
that my brain would allow
me to allow me to remember.
But I remember having a
lopsided breasts growing up.
And that was because he sucked
my breasts and he sucked
one of them mostly
and I can remember going to
the bathroom and, and it hurt.
And my mother said that, she said
she remember seeing me walk funny
around 9 or 10 years old.
And I've always had bad bowel.
So she thought I had a
had a bad bowel stuff,
but that wasn't the case.
So these are the things that
she should have picked up on
but she's always, my mother
has always had some type
of addiction she'd either
smoke weed, pop pills.
She, I mean, so she's always
been there, but not there.
We've always been physically
and materialistically provided for
but I can't remember once
hearing her say I love you.
my brother was there up
until he became like 12.
Then he started going
to youth camps and you know,
all these jails for kids.
And he was gone most of the summer
so I couldn't rely on him to be there.
So I couldn't tell him.
And erm, I think at 13, I got in trouble.
I got in trouble for doing
some ditching school.
And I'm like hell, I'm in trouble.
So I might as well get him in trouble too.
So I told her, and she sent me to live
with my best friend who stayed
around the corner from us for the summer.
And when I came back, he was still there.
And see, now he's, he's her dope, man.
He's on cocaine, this, this
is just my point of view.
I don't know what's really going on
with her because I'm trying to see it
from her point of view because I have it.
Now I have a stepbrother that, well
and half brother that
has several positive.
So erm,
they got a whole little
thing going on with them too.
And my stepbrother and
my half half-brother.
So I, but to me, it's like
you're choosing to still
stay with this man, even
though you know what he did to
me, this is what I'm saying.
So erm
she told me that if this happens again
I'm going to blame you as well as him.
Mind you. She says it to a 13 year old.
So I think about three months
later, it happened again.
But this time it was physical, he had
he actually sprang my wrist
and I told her I sprained
it at basketball practice.
So this is a girl who got
mostly, basically good grades.
And I play basketball.
I ran track, I played volleyball.
I got a job at McDonald's
anything to stay out the house.
I just didn't want to be in the house.
You know?
And she was like, why do you work?
I'm don't want to be in the house.
I don't want to be in
the house with this man.
She's not getting it.
So I go through this again
all the way up until 18.
So I was supposed to go to college
but I didn't go to college.
I joined the military,
I joined the military before
I graduated high school
because I was 18 and in the 12th grade.
So I went to the cast and
did all this and signed up.
And when she found out
she took me back up there
and she said, she can't go.
She still in high school.
And the guy said, but she signed up
for the delayed entry
program and ma'am she's 18.
She can go, she can even sign herself up.
So there was nothing
she could do about it.
Then I told her, nothings changed.
He's still doing it.
So she goes, well, why didn't you tell me?
Because I said, well,
when you, when I told
when you told me that,
if it happened again
you were going to blame
me when it happened again.
He told me now, you know, you can't tell
because she's going to
be just as mad at you.
So she said, she said.
That's not what I said.
I said, if it happens
again and you don't tell.
I said, no, that is not what you said.
You said, if it happens
again, I'm going to blame you.
At 13 ma, I believe what you said.
So I didn't tell.
That taught me how to
lie, how to manipulate
and how to try to be the
person to make everything okay.
She started dating our neighbor at 15.
I was 15.
And I kind of was like
why is every time he pulled
up on his motorcycle?
She run to the back bedroom window.
So I said, I asked her, is
that your boyfriend now?
And she started laughing.
So instead of her, she said, yeah.
So instead of her denying it
because his children were our friends
she made me their go between.
It's okay to give Bridget
a note to give to me.
Or if you want to tell me
something, you can tell Bridget.
So now I'm the go-between now
I'm really learning how to lie
and manipulate.
So as an adult,
I viewed
every relationship
with a man to me, except for my brother.
Mind you was about
what I can give them
what I can do for them.
And, and so it was really easy
for me to fall into the
prostitution of, you know
and to being used because that's what,
Hey, that's that's my life and people
- [Interviewer] Since what age?
- Five.
- [Interviewer] Five.
- So people would look at
me and they would say that
you know, damn that's hard, but it's
it's amazing how children
can adapt, adapt to the thing
to the things that happen
to the things that happened to them.
Because erm,
My neighbors, my
neighbors father came home
at 13 and he gave her a
hug and I was like, Hmm.
I was like,
I was like don't you hate
it when he touch you?
It seems like she said, no, that's my dad.
I love my dad.
And that's when I knew that something
wasn't right with the relationship
I was having with my stepdad.
We wasn't taught about being
molested and touched in school.
At that time, there wasn't bringing it up.
I didn't know what I was supposed to do
I didn't even know it was wrong
until like 13.
Really.
I knew I couldn't tell her though.
So
my,
my life kind of revolved around back
and running from feeling,
just being able to feel
my brother went when he came
out again, when I was 18
that's when he blew up because she
I literally tried to kill myself.
I took a bunch of Tylenol pills.
She, my grandmother found out
all my aunts found out and
it was a big thing then.
13, she kind of covered it up
and she didn't say anything
because my mom's the type
of person that if it
looks good, it is good.
If it looks good.
It is good.
We had the best of them
everything coming up
because she worked hard
but she wanted us to look
good, but we were fucked up.
We were fucked up, up on
the inside my brothers.
So my real dad, he's on his
alcoholic bench at this time.
And he gets sober.
I think he got sober when I
was like 15 or 16 years old.
So he's got a lot of years sober, now.
And he really wants me to get sober again.
And I think the reason why I don't get it
because I didn't think that I'm worth it.
My brother told me one time
he came down here for my birthday.
And he said we were
sitting there catching up.
While we eating, he looked at me, said
I wish I could fight your demons for you.
You got to fight your own demons.
And I wonder,
what do you think you've
done so bad in your life
that you feel like you need
to treat yourself like this,
that you deserve to be treated like this.
And I, and I was like, wow.
Wow.
And they were like, I never
thought of it like that
because I wasn't raised like this.
Like I said, if it
looked good, it is good.
But I've always been the type
of person that this is, I am what I am.
If I feel fucked up,
then I look fucked up.
And my mom has always been
what goes on in this
house, stays in this house.
But that's bullshit.
Because what goes on in this house
is not staying in his house.
Because what happens in
this house leaves with me
and goes with me everywhere I go, like
my father told me everywhere
you go, there you are.
So what are you running from?
And I don't know.
I don't know because I'm running
around here, like a chicken
with my head cut off, like
running from myself,
I guess.
I don't know.
I truly, truly don't know.
I know that I've lived a different life.
I've been sober.
I've been happy, but there's
always been a man in my life
when I've been sober.
And I know now, for the past 10 years
that having a man in your
life does not keep you sober
and does not make you happy.
My mother and my god
brother always told me
he does not mean you any good.
This man does not love
you the way you love him.
I believe he does love you
but he does not love
you the way you love him
and the way you deserve to be loved.
And I didn't hear them
because he loved me enough,
you know, because
nobody else ever did
the way I thought he did
or the way he made me think he did
until I found out that I
was more beneficial to him.
Then when I became more beneficial
to him then the love, I
was like, I can't do this.
I can't because with me,
if I love you, I love you
no matter what, good,
bad, or in differences,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what you do.
Doesn't matter how far you go we're going
balls to the walls, wheels to paint.
I'm going there with you, or
I'm going to be there for you.
And, and I'm going to accept
you for who and what you are.
Period.
That's, if I love you, I
don't care if you're bisexual
because if you, if you
take one part of you away
then you're not the same person.
So it must be, if I fell in love with you
and I find out something about you
that it must've been a part of you then.
And if you try to take it away from me.
You're going to be a different person.
And then I may not love you the same way.
But then I don't know.
That's just the way I feel
that I should be loved.
So that's the way I love people.
And it's just not reciprocated down here.
I see that.
But I can't expect for
people to love me the way
I love them.
I just need to love them
the way God expects me
to love people.
I have five kids and I do
not raise my five children
but all five of my children are raised by.
Well, four of them are
raised by their dad,
they have the same dad.
And then my fifth daughter is raised
by my dad because she
doesn't have their father.
My first four children
were my ex husband's kids
They all are drug-free.
They all are college bound.
They all are.
Well except for two of
them, they all have kids.
And they, one of them
is a Jehovah witness.
Two of them are married.
And my 19 year old's going to college.
And I'm trying to figure out God
maybe I did do the right thing
by stepping out of their
life because my mother goes,
well I did the right thing
because I was an addict.
I did the right thing
because I wasn't sure I was
the right mother for them
because see, you raised me and
and you can only do what you know
My ex husband says when you're sober
you're the best thing,
that could happen to these kids and to me.
Boyy when you put that shit in your mouth
you turn into a totally different person.
And I, and I can be
selfish I can be selfish
but I do believe that
I chose to leave them
in New Jersey, with there
family, with his family
because to bring them with
me and for them to be raised
with me or my family, I kept seeing myself
I kept seeing the cycle
and I said it has to stop.
And it stops with me and my daughter
when I told her that after I got sober
I was sober for like 22 months, 21 months.
And I went back to New
Jersey to visit them.
And they were so proud.
And they told me, don't you
ever, ever disappear on us?
We didn't know if you were dead or alive
and it was all we were worried about.
We didn't care what you did
because the truth came out.
When you left dad, it wasn't
about you doing the drugs.
It was about dad sending
you out to get the drugs.
And when you aren't here to
get sent out to get the drugs
he had to go get his drugs himself.
Then he came back
and they told me, they said, sometimes her
my oldest my two oldest
daughters said sometimes
they would talk and there'd be a room.
And they would say, you know what?
Sometimes I wish dad was dead because
if he was dead at least, we
wouldn't have to worry about you
and then they would say mom
did the best thing she could.
By leaving us here and going
to do what she had to do.
So when I showed up on Facebook
and they showed up on Facebook
and I was like, can I come visit you?
And the program that I was at,
I had been there for so long.
They let me go out of town.
They let me fly to New Jersey
for four days and visit my family.
So I'm like, okay, give it to me.
That was part of my recovery plan.
Let me, let me have it, give it to me.
And I asked them, I said
were you ever touched, I
mean, I needed to know.
And they told me no, they told me all.
They remember when we were in
when I was giving them
baths and I was telling them
these are so important to me,
these are your private parts.
Don't let anybody touch it.
I mean, as, as kids they're coming up
and I'm teaching them this
and I said, I don't care
who it is, whoever it is.
If somebody touches you
and you feel uncomfortable
with them touching you
and they won't stop.
Tell your dad, if it's
your dad, tell your aunt
if it's your aunt, tell your teacher,
tell somebody, tell them, crossing guard
keep telling until
somebody does something.
And I meant that and I
instilled it in my children.
And I told them, I tell
them, when I got on the plane
to come back here to do some recovery
and I left him in New Jersey, I said
one thing I want you to
do is never tell them
that they don't have a voice.
Never tell them to shut up
because it's all my mom told me to do.
Children want to be seen and that hurt.
- [Interviewer] So where do you stay?
- I kind of stay in the
streets, but not on the streets.
When I have a place that I can go
and sleep when I really,
really need to sleep.
Because the last time I slept in a tent
and I kind of woke up with
somebody in my tent that wasn't
in my tent when I went to sleep
and then I would take a shower
and I wasn't as clean as
I thought I should be.
And I can't like, I want to accuse him
but I didn't wake up in the middle of it.
I woke up afterwards,
but I'm getting flashes.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm getting flashes of things happening
and I'm looking at him and
I'm like you're a rapist.
And it's all changed
for you to be a rapist
in your eyes because, and he's like,
Oh so you're mad at me.
The fuck you mean, am I mad at you?
Yeah I'm mad at you
because what hurts me the
most is that I trusted you.
You know, I didn't have
any choice for myself
or it might've happened to me in the past
because I kind of thought I
did sleeping on the streets
but I didn't remember it.
So it wasn't as present
or I didn't catch it.
But I trusted, you know
I call you a friend and
this is what you do.
So if I picked you to be my friend
then there's something
wrong with my picker.
There's something wrong with me.
That these are the type
of people that I choose to be my friend.
That's what I think.
So now I've got to deal with it.
Everything comes back to me
and every choice and every
decision that I make.
So I don't know if I'm
down here trying to figure
out what type of person
that I am, or I need to be
or if I don't know, but I know I'm tired.
I'm truly, truly tired.
And I think this is
going to be my last cycle
of downtown this way.
Yeah.